enter your full name in the post webinar
survey uh you can basically find that
once we end the session which is of 60
Minutes of duration so you'll get a zoom
popup where you can fill down the post
weinar surve with your full name which
you would like to see in the certificate
of the webinar so uh I see a lot of new
folks are joining in so we just getting
started folks welcome everyone very good
morning uh to folks who have joined
us
sure sure uh so let's talk about the
agenda of today's session so we will be
getting to know a little bit about you
will be how we can help you out better
in your cloud computing career and uh
we'll be talking about cloud computing
careers in
2024 and also taking you through the
program introduction for UT delis cloud
computing boot camp and also uh through
the enrollment steps of of the program
and also there is a special duration for
the Q&A part of uh the program as well
so we will try to take as many questions
as possible when we get the time during
the session but in case we are not able
to answer all of your queries
immediately so please don't worry just
have a little patience and we'll answer
it towards the end so thank you so much
and welcome once again everyone you can
introduce uh yourself on the chart here
folks who have just joined right now we
are just getting
started and uh before we move on uh we
would love to know a little bit more
about you as I mentioned earlier so you
can see a quick pool launched on your
screen uh which says how many years of
experience do you currently have so now
when I talk about experience here I
talking about work experience here so
you can let us know through the four
quick options which you see on your
screen
also I see folks who basically are
saying that they have zero experience as
well it's totally okay can select the
option 0 to
3x sure I see most of the folks have
already shared responses for the poll
here but I think I'll just give 10
seconds more for the poll for few of the
folks who are still
basically sharing the responses for the
poll okay I think I'll just give five
seconds more for the poll
so 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end the poll
thank you so so much for sharing uh your
responses for this poll and also I'll
just quickly share the results with you
as well let's see uh what set of
experiences folks have joined us so uh
as we can see that 39% of the folks who
have joined us are currently study and
28% of the folks who have joined us have
3 to 5 of experience uh and 177% of the
folks who have joined us have three Z to
three years of experience and again like
177% of the folks have joined us more
than five years of experience so that's
great it's to see a diverse crowd here
with a different set of experiences
thank you so much for sharing that with
us
now uh would like to in introduce you
that this program is powered by simply
learn world's number one online boot
camp we have been in the digital space
for almost 13 years and we are very
proud of transforming lives by
empowering people via digital skills we
have advanced over 5 lakh plus career
with over 800 plus College qualified
trainers and also we have categories of
courses comprising from AI machine
learning data science cloud computing
which we are going to cover today devops
full stack uh product management and
many more like that so uh as we move on
I would like to welcome our speaker Andy
Le today uh Andy uh good morning to you
and uh first first of all would like to
thank you for uh you know basically
joining as a speaker for this webinar
today uh it is there is an interesting
program preview lined up of you cloud
computing Bo Camp I would love to know
uh your introduction for the crowd
here yes so welcome everybody to this uh
webinar uh I am as you can see here a
little bit younger in this
picture few years back uh so I've been
doing some Cloud architecting since um
about the
2017 uh time and uh I am a developer at
heart I started my career in development
in
1999 and basically eventually you know
graduated to the cloud and have been
bringing all my knowledge and my
experience into the cloud so I also do a
lot of Consulting and um development for
various clients uh and so I find myself
in the classroom and um on Prem so to
speak ey customer sit so I like that
synergistic effect and I think that
comes across in the classroom as well
trying to figure out what works what
doesn't work in an actual environment
and bringing that back in um I think
what's great about this uh course in
general is the fact that we're looking
at multicloud right we're looking at
Azure uh we're looking at
AWS and multicloud has become really um
a big topic as of late and uh I think
there's a lot of um benefits to going
multicloud in the job industry just
exponentially gives you a better chance
of finding
employment um and so I'm eager to talk
to you more about the details of this
course as we kind of progress through
the slide deck
here thank you so much uh Andy for your
introduction and uh yes let's move on
with the slides here let's start with
talking about careers in cloud computing
in
20124 uh so as we talking about careers
how can we miss talking about skills
here right so what exactly are the
hottest skills in cloud computing space
in24 and how exactly they'll be in
demand Andy so right now I mean even in
the cloud things are kind of changing
really fast I think
everybody's kind of been hearing a lot
about machine learning and AI especially
since chat the GPT came out uh really
this year to the to the Mass public and
so you know this has really changed the
way uh we can Leverage The Cloud because
of its elasticity the the fact that we
can just go and grab as much resources
as we're willing to pay for without
having to set it up and configure it and
now we can really get these platforms uh
up and running and configured for us so
we can just concentrate on what we want
to do maybe train a machine learning
algorithm or an AI model those kind of
things so I think the hottest skill
right now as of today is really you know
in that machine learning or AI space But
even to get there I mean there there is
a there's Stepping Stones you can't just
run right to that right so you're going
to have to know what are the cloud
providers what kind of what they offer
one over another just a lot of
similarities between the cloud providers
right they kind of just it's like having
car uh companies right everybody can
sell a car what's different from one car
manufacturer to the next it's going to
be kind of the same thing here and you
know we have here database management we
have storage Services all clock
providers offer that so this class
really hones in on how does AWS do it
different let's say than Azure what are
the good uh things that let's say Azure
does does over and above AWS or vice
versa right so you'll find yourself
maybe liking different services from
different Cloud providers and deciding
on a multicloud uh environment for that
so uh of course El elasticity
autoscaling all these kind of buzzwords
uh serverless these are all things that
we're going to learn in uh the course or
the courses there's many courses in this
learning path here but I would really
think that you know right now uh you
know getting to know you know what
storage is what networking is what
compute is what manag services is what's
serverless all these kind of things
first before going into like I said
those areas where are just massively In
Demand right now like machine learning
and
AI thank you so much for taking us
through this uh skills in the cloud
coming space which will be diban in 2024
now that we have talked about the skills
let's talk about the trending cloud
computing career paths in 2024 as well
and so I would say if you're going to
get into the cloud you first should get
a view of the the forest so to speak how
are things laid out uh because
eventually you're just going to be most
likely interested uh if you're a
developer in a handful of services right
and so if you don't really have that
Foundation before you get into the
developer services or how do we build a
a continuous integration continuous
develop pipeline those kind of things
you're going to be confused and so I
would recommend really getting into the
architecting first the architecting is
going to put you on Solid Ground show
you all the services what are the best
practices how do we build um fall
tolerant resilient scalable
architectures and then on top of that
then you can lay down whatever job role
you're really interested in doing so are
you going to work with uh devops are you
just going to be a developer so you can
see here we have um certifications like
Cloud devops engineer uh there's some
new certifications that just came out
now for data engineering data
engineering is really big as well I
mentioned before uh machine learning
right so all of these specialities or
job function roles really lay on top of
layer on top of the architect stuff so
what's great about this course is we're
going to be learning a lot about
architecture in regards to AWS and Azure
so after it'll become much easier to
reason and understand what's going on
when you want to work let's say with
security when you want to work with uh
let's say um some function as a service
in the cloud so this is how I see kind
of the career path in 2024 is pick
something that'll give you a solid
ground and then go take a look at what
interests you more right or is in line
with your job Ro but I think
architecture is really that stepping
stone definitely agree with that uh also
uh folks uh just to let you know that we
are also live on YouTube uh so a lot of
of folks have joined us there as well so
uh folks who are replying on the YouTube
live chat box do let us know if you have
any questions we'll be taking questions
from there as well
today also uh as we have talked about
the skills and the career paths in 2024
in cloud computing let's talk about
what's changing in the cloud cting space
for 2024 what's exciting you know coming
ahead as well well I think it's still
early to be too excited about Quantum
Computing uh but it's definitely moving
fast so if anybody really wants to make
a paradigm shift in the traditional uh
programming out there and go to Quantum
Computing of course you know you don't
expect to have a quantum computer in
your um in your on-prem data center so
Quantum Computing is really going to be
exclusive to the cloud right because it
just cost an immense uh uh amount of
money to to have a quantum computer and
to maintain that in a specific um uh
environment that's completely controlled
in terms of temperature so if you want
to do Quantum Computing this is already
available in the cloud in all the cloud
providers so that's something that is
really the Forefront right now you know
you have the AI stuff and you have the
quantum Computing stuff that are kind of
aart but I I see that U you know quantum
computer is or Quantum Computing excuse
me is really uh something that um will
re many benefits if you already start
getting into that right now uh
serverless serverless is something that
a lot of companies have already been
experim ING with for for several years
it kind of goes hand inand with
microservices so if you've heard of this
architectural style called
microservices um you're probably going
to be implementing that in a serverless
architecture so serverless is a funny
word because uh makes you think there's
no machines right there's no servers but
it's actually uh a marketing term which
means you know the cloud provider is
going to actually manage completely that
machine for you you won't even have
access to it so from your point of of
you there are no servers it's serverless
and so you just concentrate on what
brings business value to your company
which is maybe you developing the
application right so serverless is a big
thing uh you'll hear things like Azure
functions or AWS Lambda Dynamo DB all
these kind of technologies that are
marketed as serverless so if you're a
developer in today's age a lot of um
serverless architectures of
microservices are are highly in demand
so this kind of branches out to devops
as well uh so very very big uh business
here Edge Computing is also growing very
rapidly uh it's basically expanding
beyond the cloud providers original
Network going closer
to densely populated areas so let's say
City centers right so that we can get
much better latency and of course
performance with that so Edge Computing
is something that has been growing and
that you can definitely get into
security is always going to be important
right in the cloud we have what's called
a um shared security responsibility
model you're never you know off the hook
with security you always have something
to do with security but you know you're
still going to want to maybe secure your
applications at the edge make sure
there's no data exfiltration uh nobody
gets access to your data so security is
always going to be an important aspect
here so if you want to be a security
specialist uh that's very very good
career and a secure career in the cloud
that's about what I have to say for this
slide uh thank you so much Andy for
taking us through to what's changing in
cloud computing space for 2024 now uh we
have talked about the skills we have
talked about what career paths basically
will be trending in 20194 in cloud
computing we have also talked about
what's changing in cloud computing space
what changes are ahead and what Chang Es
are basically in the future as well
taking place so we would love to know
what exactly is stopping you from
becoming
a I think we lost you there rasher are
you
there well I think we lost you're there
okay we lost you for a second yeah sure
sure so I was talking about what exactly
is stopping you from becoming a cloud
computing expert here so we have talked
about the skills we have talked about uh
the career paths here which will be
trending in 2024 we have talked about
what exactly is changing in Cloud
competing space in 2024 so what exactly
is stopping you from becoming a cloud
competing expert or aspiring a career
towards Cloud competing here so I will
quickly Just Launch a poll here uh which
basically says what exactly stopping you
from becoming Cloud Community expert and
uh you can see four quick options there
uh this is a multiple choice question
poll so you can select multiple options
because there can be multiple concerns
or challenges you must be facing in
terms of aspiring a career towards Cloud
competing right so you can choose the
options from there and basically submit
it and in case this does not cover your
uh basically challenge or your facing or
concern you can let us know in the Q&A
box or in the chat box as well and also
for as you are basically sharing
response for this poll uh this is a
really good time to put down your
questions in the Q&A box in case you
have any questions for us you can let us
know in the Q&A box and we will be
answering your
questions uh maybe if you get time
during the session uh or else uh we have
a special duration for the Q&A part
towards the end so stay tuned till then
and uh a lot of folks who have joined uh
basically are interested for aspiring
towards a career in cloud computing and
also curious about this program as well
by UT delis so in case you have any
questions about the program in general
please do let us know we will uh we will
try to address all of your queres as
much as possible so I think I can see
most of the folks have shared responses
for this poll here so let me just
quickly end this poll I'll give last
five seconds for the folks who are still
uh sharing their responses here so 5 4 3
2 1 let me quickly end the poll and also
share the results with you folks so as
we can see that
uh 44% of the folks have shared that I
can't find a program with the fully
comprehensive curriculum and uh again
another 14 44% of the folks have shared
that my work schedule won't allow me
enough time for learning 33% of the
folks have shared that I find find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and 28% of the folks have shared
that I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready so
thank you so much for sharing that with
us now let us quickly take you through
the UDS cloud computing boot camp here
so the UDS cloud computing boot camp
comes with a comprehensive an industry
online learning path uh you get access
to integrated labs and projects for
hands-on experience and also uh the
online virtual clro with live instructor
interaction not just pre-recorded videos
but also a interaction between the
instructor and the peer as well which
makes it very interesting and also the
program duration for the uist cloud
computer board Camp is of 8 months of
duration so uh you can just complete it
by giving approximately 10 to 15 hours
per week which basically makes it very
flexible uh to fit your schedule in case
you are a working professional as well
so uh as we move on let's talk about the
utus advantage here so the University of
Texas at delis the Unis University is a
renowned institution with a rich in
history of academic excellence and it's
U basically a home to distinguished
faculty members and researchers is
fostering environment of innovation and
learning and it has been consistently
recognized as top tier uh research
universities providing students with
access to Cutting Edge knowledge and
resources and having a uis uh University
on your CV basically is very highly
respected and acknowledged
worldwide so now let's talk about the
eligibility and prosites here so uh you
may be from a non-programming background
uh and also a high school diplom
are equivalent at least 18 years of age
and no work experience is required for
joining this program so I think if you
have any questions about the program
please do let us know this is a really
good time to put down your questions in
the Q&A box uh but as we move on let's
talk about how this program builds your
skills step by step so Andy can you take
us through these uh steps here sure yeah
so what we do at the beginning of course
is like I mentioned before is we give
you a wide scope uh view of the force so
to speak what are uh those Services uh
how do they break up in certain
categories um now we have what's called
a learning management system in LMS
where this is all organized and uh the
first session you see here at the bottom
is really uh just I think one or two
hours introduction to that um system
online and makes you go through all the
options and makes you you know how to go
through the record videos how to get
access to past classes that have been
pre recorded the live training your
projects your lab environments Etc um
once that's done and you feel
comfortable with the user interface we
do our first class together and maybe
you'll have me in your class as your
instructor for the AWS Cloud
fundamentals where I kind of give you
anything from you know what is what is
the cloud why do we want to use the
cloud why is it beneficial what are the
the pros of using the cloud so we start
off with that and all the way to the end
of that class that's a couple weekends
that class or a couple of of days if
it's during the week uh I'll let Rasha
talk about the timeline of the class um
well you'll get to the point where
you'll be familiar with uh the majority
of the services in some key categories
right now don't forget AWS has over 200
Services okay so of course we're not
going to go over 200 Services because
you know nobody knows nobody knows all
the services they're always evolving but
we're going to go through the most
important ones the ones that everybody
uses okay then we're going to take it up
a notch for Designing applications and
architecture so here's where we start
delving down into specific uh services
that you'll find yourself using on a
daily basis whether they're virtual
machines or whether those those services
that fall under the category of
serverless and we look at um all the um
best practices the best design
principles the architectures we kind of
see how we fit them all together and of
course during that you know you're G to
have exercises to do you're GNA have
labs and also every course has a project
that you have to do okay so you have a
choice of three projects after every one
of these
steps and and and also basically some
exam that you have to do that you have
to get over 70% on right so we're going
to do the same thing after for the Azure
stuff okay so there's another cloud
provider from Microsoft now the nice
thing is once you finish these two AWS
courses you're not going to be starting
off all over again when you go to AIA
you're going to find yourself relearning
the same Concepts but
implemented sometimes differently
sometimes not so there's a good 30 40%
of baggage that you can bring with
yourself to another cloud provider after
so that gives you a good momentum okay
all the way up to going back to AWS at
the end devops I don't know if you guys
are familiar with or go and look at jobs
a lot but if you do you'll notice that
the word devops is showing up all over
the place the last couple of years right
and so we've added this new course onto
the curriculum the devops on
AWS to really give you even a better
chance afterwards uh to get a job as a
devops engineer so the devops kind of
puts it all together makes you create um
CI CD pipelines we call that continuous
integration continuous development
pipelines and kind of put something in
place that a company that to be working
at or maintaining that and really making
sure that again maybe a microservices
architecture is being redeployed on a
daily basis and therefore you're
supporting that by U building
maintaining observing this the vops
pipeline there now after all of this you
get to put your skills to the test by
building what's called a U Capstone
project okay so this these are Big
projects which kind of incorporate
everything you've learned and also they
will look at you know prove to us that
you can build a a multicloud uh
environment over here so since we're
looking at AWS and aure their projects
will be in line with those two Cloud
providers so lots and lots of uh
knowledge to be gained by going up this
ladder over
here uh thank you so much Andy for
taking us through the steps here how
this program basically builds your Steps
step by step so and also let's talk
about the electives here as you can see
the
CTIC basically I'm so sorry I think
cloud communing boot camp master classes
and the project and officers is
something you'll be getting uh from the
UTS and also the tools and platforms
you'll be covering in this uh course
here as you can see so many tools and
platforms and many more uh maybe Andy
you can uh take us through a few of the
tools and platform for someone who's
completely coming from a non Cloud
competing background sure so I I
actually see uh Anand here asked a
question on the chat uh would you also
be covering the deployment on ec2 and
elastic beanock for apps migrating to
AWS so this kind of goes a little bit in
line with this slide because I can see
here Amazon ec2 up on the top left so
for someone that that doesn't really
know you know anything about the cloud
which is really fine for this course
because we take you by the hand is that
ec2 is just a fancy accurate for a
virtual machine okay so a virtual
machine that you're used to working on
Prem which is basically think of that as
just a server that's been virtualized
that's how we create virtual machines in
the cloud for AWS we use an ec2 instance
and of course we have the same thing um
compute service on Asia as well we have
databases like no SQL databases if you
ever worked with a nosql database then
you'll find yourself right at home with
you know Dynamo d over here on the left
so these are document data Spa databases
or key Value Store databases that we
have here this is actually a serverless
database over here so you just create a
table and manage your schema with your
queries and everything else is managed
for you okay now for those who have some
programming experience right not
necessary but if you've ever written a
function right you've had to run that
function somewhere on some computer
right now what happens if that computer
goes down well you would need another
computer to take its place to run your
function right well all these kind of
management or administrative overheads
to run
some function some calculation well
that's what Lambda is over here it's
just a function as a service so we have
the same thing in Azure all Cloud
providers have this kind of service uh
where you write a function and you just
upload it to the cloud provider and they
will execute that function
in their
environment at scale so if you need that
function to be executed a thousand times
per second you have nothing to architect
it'll it'll happen behind the scenes
okay so all these kind of services here
whether they're virtual machines
databases function as a service DNS
containers like Docker kubernetes that
we start seeing here more on the right
hand side this is all supported with
hundreds of more Services really it's
it's it's immense Right This Cloud um
and so part of your job will be to make
sense or
relate what do we have on Prem in our
data centers what's the equivalent in
the cloud right and that you're
obviously going to learn in this course
and how to then stitch them together and
maybe even connect in a hybrid
architecture your data center on Prem
with your network work and it resources
in your Cloud
together RHA are you there thank you so
much Andy for taking us the tools and
platforms we cover in the boot uhing
boot camp and I see a lot of questions
coming in the Q&A box uh I have actually
added a few questions for you from the
YouTube live box as well and maybe you
can look at it and we can answer that
when we get time uh I've just s it to
you on chat AL Alo the Capstone projects
here I think we do have a question
related to that I I think I just shared
that on the chat so uh we getting this
uh question from s here from YouTube how
important is hands-on experience or
practical projects when entering the
cloud computing industry Andy as we
talking about the cap projects yeah well
it's it's it's it's primordial it's it's
it's super important I mean lots of job
applications they want hands-on
experience right you very common to see
that they want you know x amount of
years of hands-on experience they don't
want you just show up there with you
having some certificate answering some
you know multiple choice exam right of
course that does take some some
knowledge and skill of course but
they're going to want some hands-on
experience so
this course here uh every time you come
into a live classroom you're going to be
experiencing that going to be putting
that knowledge into practice with labs
and then after the course you'll have a
project and then after the entire course
right so let me just kind of break that
apart every time let's say we join for
four hours a day let's say you'll have a
small project to do for that session you
might even have a lab while we're doing
the 4-Hour course let's say one course
is a collection of 10 sessions right so
40 hours you'll also have to do an end
of
course project right so already there
there's a lot of experience putting that
into place then after all the
courses you have the massive Capstone
projects so you can actually take those
Capstone projects and put them on your
CV right and showcase that as your
experience because you know saying that
you've put together a multicloud
solution on your
CV speaks volumes
uh thank you so much for answering that
Andy I hope that answers the question s
please do let us know if you have any
followup question for us I think we're
getting a lot more questions but I think
uh let's move on uh to the industry
based hon project which you get to add
on your portfolio as well uh you get to
work on uh deploy a multi-time web app
using Amazon sqs deployment of a
multicloud app aure and ews connection
architecture through vpca on in this
program so we have global leaders as
program advisers Rick Hefner who's the C
who's the basically program adviser here
and also let me take you through the
learning environment of uh the urist
cloud computing Bo cam so I think I will
have to stop sharing my screen and also
quickly take take you through the live
learning environment uh so Andy you can
share your screen here yeah no problem
so what I'm going to do everyone is I'm
going
to share my screen with you I would like
if you could just confirm with me rasia
that you can see my screen right now
it's the my web browser says UT Dallas
cloud computing boot camp do you see
that yeah it is Vis Andy okay awesome uh
also is it big enough can everybody read
that or do I need to increase my
magnification
here I think you will have to increase a
little bit even for me it's it's a
little small just just yeah we are
getting 12 is good yeah I think yeah
this should be good okay so this is
basically the learning management system
also known as LMS for simply learn once
you get your own username and passwords
once you've signed up for the course you
end up on this page
okay now you'll see here remember that
slide we saw with the steps right excuse
me this is basically every step here
right minus that one or two hours that
you know shows you the LMS that's going
to be done with somebody else okay so
let's say we show up together here with
the aw's cloud fundamentals we do this
for let's say four half days and then we
get into designing applications and
architecture in AWS this is about a 10
half days a 40 hour course etc etc all
the way down until we go
to uh the Capstone projects over here
okay so let's just take a look here at
this
one
so this is where you would be spending
uh kind of many weeks on this course
over here you have a a section
self-learning okay where this is used
this is pre-recorded videos okay where
you can actually go here on the on the
right hand side and pick the topics that
you'll eventually be covering in a live
class okay so what I like to do is when
we get together is I'll let you know in
advance hey next week we're talking
about
um you know we're talking about VPC
networks you know virtual private clouds
that's what a VPC is you know I want you
to read up on lesson five as much as you
can and you kind of go here and you
start reading up on all this stuff and
watching these videos and then you show
up here let's say whatever time and
place uh we have to meet you go to live
classes and then you won't see it here
because there's none right now but
you'll see basically like a table with
the dates and some links that you click
on just like if you are accessing a a
Zoom meeting right and so you can
actually open up this uh Zoom link and I
would be there waiting for you and then
we kind of go through the class okay we
do the labs we do all that kind of
stuff then after that you know you have
some assessments uh and the assessments
are basically once you finish the whole
course right this let's say this uh this
course in particular designing
applications and architectures in AWS so
the Second Step uh you're going to have
to do one of two things you're going to
you got these two exams here okay so you
got to answer 50 questions you got to
get 70 percent now if you don't get it
the first time you got three
opportunities you even got um you can
pick either one here there's just one of
two exams that you have to pass then
after that you have to do there's one
two three four five end of course
projects so you get to pick one right so
let's say uh you pick the second one
here
and this one is going to teach you or
you by this time you already know how to
do it right I've showed you how to do
this so you kind of put it into practice
and you say I'm going to build myself a
uh database in the cloud of type MySQL
and I want to connect that to a virtual
machine running a web server an Apache
web server and so you need to secure
that you need to make sure it's publicly
accessible all that kind of stuff right
and so then you submit your project with
this button over here and there's going
to be somebody that's going to grade
that so in order to kind of pass this
course right you'll have you know in the
certificate section here it tells you to
unlock your certificate you have to get
you know you have to sit at least 80% of
the live classes right these
self-learning ones that's not such a big
deal right I mean that's that's for you
to prep for the class that's stuff
that's kind of pre-recorded um but you
know you got to sit the live classes
that's where the value is added you
could ask questions at any time here
right once you finished
80% you finish one of these you know two
exams that I said you got to get 70% and
you got to complete one of these five
projects right for example the the
database connecting to the web server
once you've got that done then you get
the certificate for this one
particular class okay and this is the
same thing over and over and over again
as you're going from the bottom of the
ladder all the way to the top now you're
going to need a lab environment to
practice right like what if you want to
practice on the side not just doing
these projects but you just want to
Tinker around right you want to do the
labs you want to do some projects all
that kind of stuff that's where the
practice labs are okay so practice labs
they give you a uh working environment
you can see here a launch lab it's going
to give you credentials to actually in
this particular case to log into what we
call the
AWS console if this was an Azure class
it'd be the same thing but you'd be
logging into the Azure portal okay so
they give you a link here right right
let me just kind of open up a a private
window all right paste that in
here and then they'll have basically a
section of course to put your username
and password let me just move this side
for two
seconds copy this just for the
screen paste and then I got this guy
here okay let me bring it back sorry I
just couldn't see two things at the same
time and I would sign in right and now
you have
access Right comes with the class you're
not going to get charged anything don't
worry right you're going to get access
now to uh the AWS console and now you
can do all these labs and things like
that right so you can go take a look at
all the services that are available in
AWS let me make this bigger for whatever
reason my browser thought it'd be funny
to go back down to
80% right so if you want to work at
databases right let me create a RDS
database that allows me to create a
mySQL database so RDS just stands for
relational database service right so I
go through all of this with you and of
course I don't have permissions right
now to do this because I haven't
officially been registered for the class
right so but you know you would go in
here and you would create these
databases and whatever else uh is asked
of you for you know the lab or the
project and things like that and that's
all part of the class okay so you can
create the environments over and over
again so right now they're they're good
for about three and a half hours once
they run out you just start another one
okay so this is all in a lab environment
over here let me go back down here I got
knocked out now that was for the
designing applications and architecture
in AWS now this will be the same thing
copy paste kind of thing all the way
down until you hit to the Capstone so
the
Capstone that's again that's when you're
kind of just about ready to graduate
and you got to really uh now spend some
time completing one of these uh three um
Capstone projects over here so you might
need to you know deployment of
multicloud app so they're kind of
telling you here they want you to set up
two load bouncers in each respective
cloud provider and then kind of connect
them together I imagine for some
Disaster Recovery scenario okay so again
this is something you can put on your CV
to show case the knowledge that you've
attained all right we also have a
community right so we have Community
forms over here you can set up your
notes you can ask for technical uh
support if ever there is a glitch uh I
myself personally speaking five star I
give these guys five stars for technical
support every time I have an issue uh
let's say I had a lab issue last time
where I just I couldn't log in for
whatever reason uh it it took like half
an hour and they fix it for me so
they're really good with that okay so
this is is your LMS system and you're
going to be here quite quite uh often
the other nice thing is every live
session that we go through together is
recorded okay so you have access to that
you might have missed a class you could
have missed an hour something like that
or you just want to go back and see I
you know what I was teaching in regards
to
um do you know containers ECS in Asia uh
sorry in um in AWS so you kind of go
back to that section and refresh your
memory okay so that's pretty much what I
have to say here for
um cloud
computing uh I have to find just a
second here my um stop share maybe razza
if you can stop my share for me but if
not I have to find my window sure sure
let me share back my screen no worries I
can actually I found it yeah I found it
yeah sure oh by while you were speaking
also Andy um we did get a question about
the learning environment uh as you can
see by Malcolm on the chat here will we
be getting materials books and PDF files
yeah so all the slides that I showcase
all the materials that I Showcase in the
course while we're doing the live
sessions are available to you uh and
there's some also uh lab files the PDFs
for the steps all that kind of stuff is
available in the lm's a little like
Arrow where you kind of download that
now that kind of stuff I didn't go into
the Nitty Gritty details of everything
because you have a two-hour seminar
right on um the LMS system that's the
first step of that ladder you know and
they'll they'll show you know how you
you know access the live training how
you access the recorded material how you
download the materials all that kind of
stuff thank you so much Andy for
answering that I hope Malcolm that
answers your question also please do let
us know if you have any followup
questions for us so we just went through
the learning environment of uist cloud
computing Bo Camp moving on uh we have
global leaders as program advisers we
have Professor D baa who basically is
the department head at the University of
Texas at Dallas we have Professor
Benjamin uh who basically is the
associate professor at University of
Texas dasis and uh basically we have one
more Global advisor as well basically
they all come with a huge amount of
experience and they make sure that
simply learn is delivering as per UTS uh
standards and uh job assist Services uh
we have Partnerships with Talent Inc
here where we have partnered up with
them in order to
give access to the premium resume rabbit
job portal service with a white employe
Network and also a resume review and
reite Service as well uh also you get
access to oneone interview Service as
well through taling here so I think we
have a few few more questions on the
program here but I think we'll just
answer uh one on the Q&A box I think
we'll take it up it's pretty relevant
I'll just uh ping you that Andy on the
chat here because might be difficult
sure rash I'm just going to say there's
a lot of qu I mean I didn't read them
all I read at least half though I think
the first three
questions uh you know in terms of job
placement experience uh which who's
hiring all this kind of stuff that's
more on this slide that you're talking
about there is a assistance service by
SAR to help you with this right you know
nobody can guarantee anything uh but you
have support in finding a job whether
you have zero experience or 10 years of
experience there is a support um arm
there so to speak from the simply
learned program which is something
usually you don't see in other programs
um now is this course accessible and a
Africa that's a question that I actually
don't know the answer to maybe Rashid
would you know the question to
that uh what I can do is I can share the
link towards the program in case uh you
can check it out for your own region as
well uh this currently is accessible
only to us candidates uh so but uh if
you want to check it out still I can
share the link towards the program uh in
in few minutes uh meanwhile do you want
to see more questions as well yeah the
the like okay so I think the first four
questions on the Q&A like said the first
three that has to do with the job
assistance service okay uh then there's
one in regards to okay what is the UT
involvement that I you know that that's
something more maybe in the background I
I'm not too sure what the UT involvement
is what makes this devops program
different from the others offered by
simpar well I mean just from my point of
view I would say it's part of a larger
curriculum so you'll get more EXP
exposure to those services in other
lenses what I mean by that is you'll see
them from a developer's point of view
you'll see them from an architectural
point of view you will see them from a
cloud operations or sised Min point of
view so by getting all those kind of
different
lenses um you're going to be a better
devops developer than just getting a
very focused devops training which
you're going to get anyways in that
class so it's it's it's more the the sum
of the parts are are greater than the
whole here uh and the other thing is is
you'll probably have me and that's
that's a good thing I teach it in this
curriculum not in the in the one that's
all by itself
um last question I see here in the
question answer is is all the content
available via written material uh For
Those whom videos are not the ideal
learning platform yeah so I I might have
answered that in passing before because
we had the question here in the chat
window is yes you have all the all the
materials are available in PDFs uh there
of course you don't get access to the
actual uh you know MP3 files or anything
like that the videos stay on the
platform but the PDFs are all from the
slides you know hundreds of slides Are
all uh downloadable to your
computer okay and um yeah I think that's
basically so the other question here I
have Rashia I'm looking at the chat
window
now
um okay so I have here does one have to
start from the cloud foundations I think
if you sign up for this course I mean
you have to start from the bottom to the
top you can't join in from like from on
step number three am I right there Asha
yeah yeah exactly okay and uh so that's
uh uh kihindi that's your question and
the other one is how uh Cindi again how
long is the cloud uh Computing boot camp
I think what did you say before one one
of the slides before the whole thing was
was how many uh how many weeks we can
just go back to it just yeah it was
actually written on one of those slides
yeah it's eight months and eight months
there go yeah and can just completed by
giving approximately 10 to 15 hours per
week for the Cs Cloud cting boot camp I
hope that answers your question I think
we have taken plenty of questions here
uh from the Q&A box and the chat as well
we do have few more uh we are uh
basically uh running a little bit our as
well we just have few minutes left so uh
so we have talked about the skills here
we have talked about the career paths
which be in demand in 2024 we have also
talked about uh the projects you can
work on through this program we have
talked about the learning environment uh
what exactly happens in the simply
learns learning environment of this UT
deis cloud computing board cam so we
would love to know are you interested in
enrolling in the UT delis cloud
computing board cam you can see a quick
poll launched on your screen
here which says what you like to IND R
into the program uh you can share your
interest towards enrollment into the
program here and also for folks who are
sharing interest I'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps of the
program uh and also the upcoming cohart
and the program fee as
well meanwhile if you have any questions
about the program you can let us know I
think someone has asked about the cost
of the program I will be sharing that in
the upcoming slide and also the upcoming
carts as well which you can take up and
also we would love to know when exactly
do you plan to enroll during the next
year so we have those options as
well meanwhile as I was speaking I see a
lot of interest towards the endowment so
that's great that's positive uh
meanwhile uh folks who are sharing
interest towards enrollment uh if you
have any questions about the program in
general or career in general in cloud
computing please do let us know we do
have few minutes left where we can
address your queries as
well I think I just give 10 seconds more
for the poll here as folks are sharing
the responses for the poll
here and also I think uh for someone who
basically has joined from Africa region
I have shared the link of the program uh
for you not able to make out the name uh
from the email ID I'm so sorry so you
can check out uh basically the program
uh details for your own region uh in
case you want to check out you're
joining from a different
country apart from the US but do the
classes start I'll be sharing that but
the classes start from Feb 2024 that is
the upcoming code that will be around
approximately that month of next year
but the induction will be pretty early
for
that I think last five seconds for the
poll here so uh are you interested in
enrolling into uis cloud computing Bo
boot camp here you can let us know
through this poll there are two two
quick options in this poll here yes or
no you can share your interest towards
enrollment by clicking on
yes uh I think yeah I think someone has
asked for the link here let me do one
thing let me share the link towards the
program on the chat here as well for you
folks last 5 seconds for the poll here
folks uh the is still moving so I'll
give last five seconds for the poll
meanwhile I'm sharing the link to whatsa
program here on the chat so you can
check it out uh the utls cloud cting
boot camp link towards the program for
your own region here and uh maybe the
program fee and the upcoming cohorts
might vary for the program so you can
check out that for region so I think
last 5 seconds for the poll here so for
the folks who are still thinking about
it you can share your response here and
also uh basically simply learns learning
consultant will'll be taking you through
much more detailed walk through the
program as well if you basically share
your interest towards ening through this
PO so last 5 Seconds 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the
poll thank you so much for sharing your
interest towards enrollment now let me
quickly take you through the enrollment
steps here so uh there are three simple
easy steps you will have to follow once
simply learns learning Consultants will
be reaching out to you U with the
admissions offer so they will be
basically taking out through these three
simple easy steps you need to submit an
application at uh ask us at simply
learn.net and then uh UT D will be
reviewing your qualifications based on
the eligibility and the prer sites I've
shared with you earlier and based on
that you'll be getting admission um from
um learning Consultants from c will be
contacting you with the admissions offer
letter so that is the process they'll be
taking um basically you in much more
detail now uh talking about the upcoming
program schedule and also the fee here
so the next upcoming gooh will be
starting around Feb and uh induction
might start much earlier next year 2024
then the program fee for this program is
$8,000 uh USD including taxes and we
also have financing options available
for as low as $74 per month uh in case
you have any queries you can always
reach out to us at ask us at s.net I'll
share that email ID on the chat in case
uh you have any questions you can reach
out to us there immediately I'm just
sharing that email ID for folks who have
any more questions are not answered and
also just to let you know that we have
very limited seats per cohart we only
take 25 to 30 folks per cohart in order
to make sure that you're getting all the
attention that is required when you're
taking up this program now uh for folks
who have already shared with us the
interest towards enrollment we would
love to to know how soon do you plan to
enroll so now through this poll which
I've launched right now you can see on
your screen uh this will give us an
understanding when exactly do you plan
to enroll and which cohart will be the
most suitable for
you uh for next year so as you so there
are multiple calls that happen
throughout the year so uh this poll
definitely is for the folks uh which is
a lot of you have shared interest
towards enrollment into GS cloud
computing board
camp also someone has asked uh yes we do
have a certificate for the webinar uh
basically you will get it uh basically
once uh we end this uh webinar that is
basically in few minutes I think five to
seven minutes max uh we'll take any
pending questions if we have time and
once the webinar ends you will get a
zoom webinar popup for post webinar
survey where you can basically enter
your full name there and also you can
share us with us any feedback you have
to we a webinar right up so uh I see
that most of the folks have shared
response for the poll but I think last 5
Seconds uh for folks uh who basically
have already shared interest towards
enrollment so how soon do you plan into
the uh plan to enroll into the program
so you can see four quick options here
immediately in case you're planning to
join the immediate upcoming cohort which
is in the next two to three months uh
and also within 3 months within 6 months
and more than 6 months from now for
folks who are still thinking about it
and yet not sure when basically are they
planning to join this definitely will
give us understanding when to reach out
to you with the admissions offer and the
enrollment steps of the program so last
side seconds 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll thank you so much for
sharing that with us and let's see if
you have any pending questions uh in the
Q&A box or from our YouTube live chat
box as
well mostly what I see here is related
to you know uh cost or uh subsidiary
scholarship things of that nature uh you
know average salary of a cloud engineer
in India I I don't have those numbers
off the top of my head at all that's
something maybe you could you know email
uh to
that but uh yeah obviously that's going
to depend per per country right um in
regards to the uh Malcolm here in Kenya
we were just saying that you emailed a
or not emailed but you sent a link there
for uh the Learners in Africa
um I'll just share that once again yeah
I think that kind
of yeah I think uh we have actually
answered uh most of the questions
throughout the session and also uh we
have whatever pending we had as well on
the chat and also from the YouTube live
chat box so folks uh we would love to
know if you need any assistance in
enrolling to the program there's a quick
poll you can see on your screen uh which
basically says yes or no uh this is this
is for folks who need uh extra help in
case you're a working professional and
you need some extra help you don't have
time uh to you know go in and roll and
follow the steps by your own own so uh
learning consist from Simply Lear
definitely will help you out uh with
much more assistance uh in enrolling
into the UDS Cloud competing board Camp
so you can select the option yes here in
case you need assistance if not then you
can select the option no here this is
for the folks who have already shared
interest towards enrollment and also
have let us know when do they plan to
enroll um I think someone is asking is
there a free to obtain the certificate
uh the webinar certificate is obviously
free the attendance for attendance I
think that is something you have asked
so I hope that answers your question and
I'll just keep this PO live for 5
seconds more we are towards the end of
the session here
I also had a question here from Perth uh
scope of cloud computing field last sa
I'm not too sure what last sa means
there in that question but the scope of
computing is the spectrum is enormous
there is no uh you know there is no
Niche it's not a niche um technology
it's it can run any kind of workload in
there so whether like we're just talking
about AI machine learning uh database
Quantum Computing uh anything you can
run on Prem you can run in the cloud as
well thank you so much for answering
that Andy I hope that answers your
question prit uh from the chat from the
Q&A box and
uh I think uh we are towards the end of
the session uh for folks who if you I
have any more questions about the
program you can always reach out to us
at ask us at simple.net please feel free
to uh mail us there your queries there
we will we will basically addressing in
their post session and also uh for folks
who have shared interest in enrollments
like we we're looking forward to see you
in the upcoming CS of ug delis Cloud
competing board camp and also for Andy
uh thank you for joining us and taking
the time out for the program preview for
The U Cloud commuting board Camp would
you like to say something to the folks
here before we end session yeah it was a
pleasure meeting you all thank you for
taking the time to be with us and
hopefully I'll see you uh as early as
February in the AWS class see you on the
cloud so much thank you folks thank you
for being an amazing audience here uh
please do let us know how did you like
the session uh you can let us know on
the chat box here and also basically
once the webinar and put in the post
webinar surve as well also for the
webinar certificate you can put down
your full name there I think someone
asked about that thank you so much thank
you thank
you bye
everyone bye-bye folks have a have a
good
day